now there are many reasons to be in a
great mood going into this weekend
because the good news keeps coming now
first and most obvious Donald Trump blew
everyone out of the water in Iowa which
means that the party is uniting now it's
only a matter of time before Nikki Haley
and Ronda santis who both gave it a good
go will drop out and if they're smart
they'll endorse them now taking on Biden
and the billionaires supporting Biden is
going to require all hands on deck and
laser beam focus on turnout mail and
ballots and ballot
harvesting the second piece of good news
Trump provided some clarity about his VP
pick and Haley is not on the list well
truth be told she's just not a good fit
and he doesn't need a Liz Cheney type as
his backup and a third bit of good news
the uni party has its backup against the
wall on the immigration issue the Senate
negotiations are a bait and switch as
I've been telling you for the last week
president Trump has smartly and strongly
come out against it now the final
product will give Democrats everything
they want their Ukraine money and the
flexibility for Biden to keep releasing
migrants into the United States but what
do we get in return essentially nothing
now Republicans say Laura just wait
until we see what's in the bill the text
of the bill but what I'm telling you
tonight is that's naive because the
details are irrelevant we know that
mayorcas and Biden are never going to
enforce the Border despite all the phony
hype by Schumer speaking in the Senate
we are making really good progress I am
more optimistic now that we can come to
an agreement on border and Ukraine in
one package I am more optimistic than
ever before that we'd come to an
agreement if the cries for help from
Liberal Mayors didn't compel them to
stop The Invasion words in the
Congressional Reg Minister sure aren't
going to compel Biden and my orcus to do
the right thing so give me a break now
the good news is that the GOP Grassroots
has never been more united on this issue
and Democrats as a result they are
panicking now they're even trying to
pressure speaker Johnson to let the
Senate deal go forward and in return
they'll give him votes to help him
survive any leadership challenge now
these implicit threats will not go over
well even Politico knows how pathetic
that this makes Democrats
seem now the fact that some of these
Liberals are even talking about the idea
shows how desperate they are to find a
solution the party knows that time is
running out to help Ukraine and they're
getting pummeled on the border issue
politically and need to do something to
alleviate the
situation now precisely they're getting
pummeled on the border issue and yet
there are Republicans Republicans who
want to throw Biden and Company a
Lifeline now again neither party has
Clean Hands here because if they really
believe that Russia was an existential
threat and that money's needed for
Europe to save Europe well that Europe
is going to be somehow buried by Putin I
should say well if that was the case
Senate Republicans would demand that
Biden sign a bill that includes the
provisions which are tough s I
Provisions in
hr2 and then that would be followed by a
period of several months of enforcement
to show that Biden and Company will
actually do enforcement in other words
show good faith on the deal but
McConnell and Langford and th they're
never going to demand this and they
aren't doing it and by the same token if
Democrats truly truly believe that Trump
was an existential threat to democracy
that he was Hitler well they would close
the border immediately just to take the
issue away from him but neither party is
going to do the right thing here because
their top priority is to keep the Border
open and the flow of millions of
migrants coming
here establishment Republicans want the
cheap labor for their donors and
Democrats want to change America
demographically to win elections in the
future this my friends is a classic
Unholy
Alliance but the good news so far
Speaker John
has played this really cleverly he's
forced the Senate's hand and now voters
are going to see what really matters to
everyone notice that the man Republicans
decided to keep as minority leader Mitch
McConnell he's not going on any of the
shows is he certainly not coming on this
show to explain why any of this makes
any sense and I'll tell you why he
doesn't because he can't again this is
nothing personal I have great respect
for the Senate leadership but this
immigration Showdown simply confirms
that it was a huge mistake not to
replace McConnell as
leader and even when the news isn't good
at least the truth is becoming clearer
and that is good like the truth about
EVS now remember when Biden made his
visit to Detroit to tour and look at and
inspect all the great new
EVS look folks uh you know uh the Great
American road trip is going to be fully
electrified whether you're driving coach
to coast along I 10 or on I75 here in
Michigan charging stations will be up
and easy to find as gas stations are
now oh those charging stations are
really working well well that was then
and this is now because Americans just
aren't buying it and they're not buying
them as in the EVs and many who have
actually bought the electric vehicles
aren't loving them man this is crazy
it's it's it's a disaster seriously has
it been charging no not at all it just
isn't working at all it's just Frozen
and so I'm now I'm getting tow to the um
test the service center because that's
my only option at this point I've had to
charge like multiple times every day the
last couple
days their ranges are too variable and
the EVS are not reliable in cold weather
so Ford just announced it's scaling back
production of its electric
F-150s which is a massive blow to the
auto maker that boasted about their
Innovation when the truck was first
introduced now Republican candidates
have to warn voters that if they want to
preserve gas powered cars and all the
freedom that goes along with them and
also Gas Appliances Etc they will need
to defeat Democrats across the
board and finally there's good news out
of Georgia we're we're just learning how
much fanny packs as in Fanny Willis
packing to go go on vacations sorry work
trips with her very married and her very
special prosecutor Nathan Wade documents
released by a source in Wade's divorce
trial where M Willis is fighting a
subpoena give us more details about how
busy the duo has been who knew that
putting together an election
interference case against President
Trump would require so much Caribbean
travel such as multiple purchases in
October of 2022 from from the Royal
Caribbean Cruise Line an American
Airlines ticket to Miami in November
2022 purchases included a Hyatt resort
in Aruba in the Norwegian Cruise Line
2023 purchases included The Rum Runners
Freeport the island Jeep and Car Rental
Freeport and some Delta airline tickets
and some nights at the Double Tree and
well Napa Valley a lot of work can be
done there so what's the good news here
well it's that Georgians are now seeing
the corrupt system system in Fulton
County where hiring lovers and
vacationing on the taxpayers dime seems
to be the norm and these are the people
by the way with their values who have
the power potentially to change the
future of America with this prosecution
of President
Trump this is obscene and it's absurd
and the good news is next November the
voters will know it so it's time to send
Fanny packing that would be very good
news and that's the angle hey Sean
Hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to Fox News YouTube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else